comedy begins where tolerance
ends why because when you reach people
to the point where they're
nervous they start to store tension and
the more tension they
store the more explosively they will
release that tension in the form of a
laugh when the laugh comes basically
they're thinking how bad is this going
to get how far is he going to go how
much is this going to cost me
this is bad and if the punchline to the
joke takes all of that tension and
relieves it with the defeat of
expectation then not only do do I get
the defeat of expectation I get the
release of tension we can examine this
space by looking at what is taboo and we
can note that in any group Nation
culture Community neighborhood social
group club sports team there are things
that are allowed and things that are not
allowed and the line will always be
different from group to group jokes that
are allowed in same-sex groups are
different from jokes that are allowed in
mixed gender groups jokes that are
allowed to adults are different from
ones that are allowed to Children if you
tell a joke that's right there on the
edge of what's allowed for your group
that's when people will get nervous
that's when they'll start to get up
tight and that's when you can milk that
tension and store it and then pop it
like a
balloon
uh I do this exercise in a lot of
cultures where I teach mostly because
I'm interested I like to ask the
question what's taboo here what's Taboo
in modern Germany is it still taboo to
talk about World War II is it taboo to
talk about religion is it taboo to talk
about politics is it talk taboo to talk
about gender I don't know but once you
tell me what's taboo I can tell you
exactly where to find the joke
which is right where people start to get
nervous right now there's a corollary
expression comedy begins where tolerance
ends the cor expression is the trouble
with too far is you never know you're
going till you've gone this takes us
back to will to risk I have to if I'm
going to explore the area of taboo I
have to be willing to risk going too far
because I'm never going to land on the
right spot every time there's a great
example of this that I talk about in the
comic toolbox Robin Williams's doing
standup comedy and he tells a joke that
the audience does not approve of I don't
remember what it was but you could just
hear an audible gasp everybody like oh
Robin you went too far and in the next
moment he said something that boiled
down to I went too far didn't I he
didn't use those words exactly but it
was the understanding he acknowledged
that he had gone too far and everybody
in the audience said oh well he knows he
went too far it's okay he bought back
their loyalty so it's possible to go too
far if you go too far you can always buy
it back just by saying oops I went too
far where you lose is where you go too
far and you don't acknowledge it because
then you create a a wall between
yourself and the audience I I describe
it as a rift in the fabric of space
something just happened and you're not
acknowledging it and the audience knows
you're not acknowledging it and they're
no longer your fan they're suffering for
you because they see you suffering the
minute you say I made a mistake but it's
okay you're no longer suffering so
they're no longer suffering and they can
go back to enjoying you as you can see
it's a complex puzzle but what's
exciting about it is to apprehend it as
a puzzle so that you're not just
creating jokes in a vacuum you're not
just trying to write something funny and
hope they laugh but you have an
understanding of what works for one
audience is different from what works
for another audience and knowing how to
manipulate that space um let's imagine
that I have a gig this is from the the
the little book of standup let's imagine
that I have a gig and I'm addressing
people who make humy oh no fans of
Humvees you know those big gas guzzling
cars I'm no fan of Humvees and I might
say to myself this is not my space but
if I just think about it I can say to
myself what's on their mind what do they
care about they got these big hulking
hulking cars probably hard to park I
have trouble parking in my car I can
talk about that so now I can connect
with the audience with something that is
of concern to them how do I park this
Beast without avoiding any of the
potential conflict areas that I might
not want to get into on the other hand I
might take the
approach you people know you're stupid
right let's just imagine this I'm
telling a lie to Comic effect I'm
definitely going to land a laugh on that
cuz people don't know me yet they don't
know that I mean it they probably expect
that I don't mean it so they're willing
to kind of take the first blow you
people know you're stupid to drive these
gas-guzzling cars don't you if I then
turn around and reveal
my misunderstanding of what a Humvee
driver
is I can win their loyalty I can poke
fun at them I can make us all part of a
group experience and then I can take
them to the edge you know let's just
imagine that you're driving your Humvee
only it's not a Humvee it's a limousine
and it's prom night what's going on in
this limousine on promite oh says the
audience limousine on promite in my humy
I'm intrigued tell tell me more and I
might take you to a dangerous spot there
I can go to some dangerous places on
prom night but I've set you up to take
that Journey with me by building a bond
of trust and a bond of common
understanding between you and me so when
we say that comedy begins where
tolerance ends we can also say you get
to Define where tolerance ends you can
push them farther than they think they
can go simply by taking them there with
you well it seems like some groups there
might be more tabos and some less I mean
you talked about going to concerts and
sort of this counterculture sort of
experience I would imagine there's
probably less tabos there absolutely uh
the way I like well well I mean of
course they're going to go for the the
drug humor won't be taboo um there's a
lot of behaviors that won't be tab it's
like late night television the rules on
late night television are different from
the rules of daytime television because
the audience is different here's the way
to think about it an audience is a bell
curve goes like this
and at one end of the bell curve are
people who won't get the joke because
they don't know enough or they don't
accept enough these are people who are
intolerant at the other end of the bell
curve there are people who won't get the
joke because they know it already
they've heard it before or it just
doesn't bother them they over accept it
they too tolerant our Target is always
the big fat middle these are people who
have enough tolerance to understand what
we're getting at and enough intolerance
to feel nervous so they'll laugh the big
fat middle will shift if it's a late
night show the big fat middle is over
here more sophisticated if it's a
children's television show The Big Fat
mid is over here much safer if it's
Teletubbies it's way over there
somewhere our job is as strategic
creators is to ask ourselves what's the
big fat middle for this audience how can
I play to it and then how can I push it
because if I both play to it and push it
it'll be a more satisfying experience
for the audience if I just play to it
they'll say yeah okay that was fine that
was funny but it didn't teach me
anything if I put it and get them to
think about something in a way that
they're unused to thinking about no
matter what their level of Tolerance is
something will push their buttons If I
strategically push their buttons then I
reward them with comedy and with insight
and that's where creativity starts to
play for higher Stakes I was reflecting
on this
earlier there was a time in my career in
in my early career when I reached a
crossroad in my writing and the question
was was am I going to continue to write
funny or I'm going to write something
different and I remember very clearly
thinking to myself knowing in my heart
that I wanted to play for higher Stakes
I wanted to talk about and think about
the kind of things that we're talking
about and thinking about
now but I look back and I
say what how different would my life be
if I had made that different choice if I
had said first let's completely Crush
comedy and then turn our attention to
serious that is an option that I didn't
realize I had at the time I felt like I
had to make a move and make it now I
might not have been wrong but there's
always a sense of the road not taken and
what I'm reflecting on now is in that
moment I felt that I didn't have any win
bigger than making them laugh I didn't
realize that I could make them laugh and
make them change at the same time I
could bring them to a new place
so since learned you can do both when
you talked about push them the the bell
curve you're it's going to be constantly
moving when you say push the audience
does that mean kind of like taking them
right up into the line of what may be
inappropriate kind of like flirting with
it yes okay okay yeah and and how are
you going to find out how to flirt with
that line effectively trial and error
which means you're going to bomb so
badly but every standup comic comic will
tell you if you haven't bombed you're
not in craft you you you must die on
stage over and over again in order to
understand what your business is about
on stage CU otherwise here's my set the
intention for my set is to not
fail if my intention is to not fail I'm
going to play it safe right I'm never
going to take a chance because I'm
afraid of failing which means that I
never grab the Brass Ring of making them
change how they think if my intention is
to make them change how they think amuse
them to new enlight amuse them to
Enlightenment let's say if that's my
goal I know for sure it's not going to
work every time I'm going to go too far
not far enough there will be failure and
it will be
spectacular but I can't get the big win
I want unless I risk the big failure so
I have to find some way to say it's part
of the process people bomb all the time
let's go for
it I mean Andy Kaufman style uh on the
Letterman
type exactly everything Andy Kaufman
ever did was pushing the envelope in
Extreme Ways and I can certainly
understand his motivation to do so this
is going to be such a great joke on the
audience and I think where people have
trouble with Andy Kaufman myself in a
way is that for all of his body of work
he never let the audience being on the
joke with him it was always at their
expense and and we talked earlier about
having an image that fits your nature I
would never take that approach because I
don't want to hurt those people I don't
want to fool them at their own expense I
want them to enjoy my reality with me
not in opposition to me but a thousand
Comics Andrew d clay um uh uh Sam
Kennison the list of conflict
confrontational Comics is long and this
tells us and this is another Super
important Point comedy has a lot of
different powers but broadly speaking it
has two Powers the power to lift up and
the power to knock down and both of
those powers are valid I choose to lift
up that's where I live comically but
people who use comedy to attack are
playing a vital role in society they're
telling people what's wrong if you're
passionate to get people to think
differently about that you're going to
have to make them feel it and you might
take some chances that don't pay off if
they don't want to feel it if they're
resisting you have to overcome their
resistance so you're using comedy to
break down in order to create something
better this is this is what comedy does
it reinforces social norms and at the
same time it destroy social norms and
it's so weird that it does both so I
always tell people when you're doing
stand-up comedy if you want to destroy
destroy I'm never going to tell you not
to do that I'm not a destroyer I'm a
builder uper and I always will be I
might try destroying to see how it
feels but that's not where I live or or
if somebody's really boxing with you you
might take a couple SS but but if if
we're playing nice sure but if if well
and people put themselves in that
situation you have rat battles or roast
battles where two Comics stand toe to-
toe insulting each other I would fail so
badly I I I
wouldn't I think I'd probably have the
the the flexibility in the moment to
come up with the jokes but I'm not sure
that I would have the wherewithal to say
them I think the taboos that exist in me
would be too strong to take me there
effectively at least on the first try
sure but then when I hear myself say
that I say well make a note try that
because how else you're going to grow
let's call it a black hole there's a
black hole that says hey John vorous
you're afraid of being an insult comic
maybe you better try it just so you can
experience not being afraid of it well
what if someone's taking some real
cutting uh blows at you and and maybe
they're not trying to be funny so you
think all right I'm going to head him
back with some humor but it's going to
have a little bit of a sting to
it I wouldn't even do that I'll tell you
why because first of all no matter what
they directed me it's probably not going
to make me feel bad because
I'm self what what I'm self monitoring
oh okay actualized I'm I'm
self-monitoring and I'm not I'm I'm not
taking in that information thinking at
all about how does it make me feel I'm
not thinking about how other people
think about me I'm not worried about any
of that I'm just present in the moment
that's my normal operating Behavior at
this point so it's it's can be hard for
me to be legitimately angry in the
moment and even if I am legitimately
angry and I want to strike back I'm
probably going to want to strike back in
a way that builds Bridge because all
things considered I'd rather have that
friend that person as a friend than an
enemy as a as an ally than an enemy and
engaging him in conflict or her in
Conflict won't necessarily get me to the
goal that I want there's a lot going on
you you can be very sophisticated about
this stuff and it all starts with the
understanding that operating effectively
with other people in any realm starts
with operating effectively Within the
way that I put it is you can read
people's minds you can know 90% of
everything everybody is thinking all the
time the trick is to read your own mind
because most of everything everybody
thinks is the same stuff so if you're
articulate in your own self dialogue if
you know yourself in concrete terms then
you know everybody else in the same way
um I think about this when I'm in the
classroom what do I what what's on these
people's minds what are they afraid of
well if I were them I'd be afraid of
being called on I'd be afraid of being
asked to tell a joke and have it be not
funny how do I know that how do I know
you feeling that way cuz I'd feel that
way and 90% of everything everybody
thinks is the same stuff all right with
this awareness now I can give you a gift
I can relieve you of that
fear in a thousand different ways and
all of them are jokes I I I would say to
you
um uh everybody here who's afraid to
tell a joke raise your hand oh nobody
will raise their hand because they're
all afraid to tell a joke okay everybody
who's not afraid to tell a joke raise
their hand and whoever raises their hand
I pick on some pick somebody else and
you can manipulate the situation
effectively to serve your goals and
other people's goals simply by having at
the same time self-awareness and other
awareness
again in the book of practice I talk
about something called a win-win
situation when you look at a situation
and you say this is what this person
wants and I can give it to them and
that's what that person wants and I can
give it to her and if I give them both
what they want then I'm going to be seen
as somebody who empowers other people
and that's what I want so it's a win for
him it's a win for her it's a win for me
that's wins all around and I can have
that anytime I want simply by allowing
myself to examine the situation honestly
and
objectively that's great so you talk
about jokes that build Bridges and then
jokes that burn them yes mhm interesting
and and you can absolutely do that and
you see H you see Comics do it all the
time can you think about a comic you've
seen who blew up on stage lost it
completely and started yelling at the
audience being angry at the audience for
not meeting the comics
expectation I can that is a comic who is
trying to ease a psychic pain the pain
the current flaming hurt of failure I'm
bombing and I know it and I'm so
desperate not to feel bad that I'm going
to attack those people there the attack
doesn't really achieve that goal you
kind of feel better CU you scratched the
urge to rage but you didn't win any fans
you came off kind of looking
ridiculous it might have been better off
if you just said well that didn't work
I'm going to give my time back to the
room and walk off
stage I've known people that have gone
to comedy clubs and been the subject of
attacks yes and and left in tears and
they weren't the comic they were the
they were you know it they were in the
audience well and and that's a different
kind of strategy and that strategy is
let's bond together by attacking a
common enemy we'll all make fun of that
guy we'll brutalize that guy and we'll
all laugh cuz it's not us and then I the
comic and you the audience we're
together against that common enemy Don
Rickles is a classic example of that and
again it's somebody's idea of a good
time and and I know people who love
being attacked they want to Heckle and
get shot down mercilessly it satisfies
them little bit of reflected Glory a
little bit of participation a little bit
of I don't know um it it hurts so good
kind of thing endorphin stimulation like
getting a tattoo or eating hot sauce you
know if I can make myself the object of
the comics attack and he really gives it
to me good it hurts but it kind of feels
good hey I was the object of everybody's
attention that feels good yeah there's a
great clip with Kevin Smith at ComiCon I
don't remember what year it was but
somebody kind of challenged him one of
the fans in the audience and he's good
he takes it and he he he he's good and
then then he flips it and he just gives
it to the guy and the whole place cheers
and excellent that and that talented
practitioner is three steps ahead of his
mouth in his
mind I do this all the time I'm not a
I'm not a Kevin Smith but I know what it
means to launch a joke without really
knowing what the punchline is going to
be but knowing that I'll find it by the
time I need it yeah he's really skilled
yes